[Music]
hey what is up guys in cabbie HD here
and the LG g4 has been killing it this
[Music]
is LG's big and bright and slightly
curved flagship smartphone for 2015 for
most of my phone reviews you'll notice
it's pretty much a combination of the
pros and the cons about the device the
pros being things that I really like
about it and then the cons being the
list of things that I think could be a
little bit better and going through all
the things I've written down and all the
notes I have about the g4 during my time
using it it's mostly pros there's not a
lot that's wrong with this phone at all
and it pretty much checks all the boxes
in terms of things you'd want to see in
a high-end smartphone anyway let's get
into it
first of all on the spec sheet the g4 is
high-end all the way across the board
you saw at the date was announced so
it's rocking a six-course Snapdragon 808
chip 3 gigabytes of RAM and it
benchmarks a little bit lower than that
Snapdragon 810 but that's not a big deal
definitely still an excellent performer
and the rest of the components like the
display and the battery and the camera
as you'll see in a second are top of the
line too but let's start with the build
since this was actually my least
favorite part of the phone it has a 5.5
inch display so it's kind of a big phone
and it's slightly curved so not flexible
curved like the LG G flex 2 and it grew
its forehead back from the g3 which had
those trademarked much thinner bezels so
I'm saying the g4 is not the prettiest
phone in the world but material choices
are decent so you get a glossy metal
sides and you can get it with a variety
of different backs but that I have here
is the plastic one LG says this is a
plastic infused with metal but I can't
really tell so I'm just gonna call it
plastic and it has a sort of a diamond
pattern to it that you can feel when you
rub your hand on it there's another back
material that's ceramic a bit heavier
and a bit smoother but with the same
diamond pattern and there's also a bunch
of leather ones which actually look
really nice and although I don't know
how durable they are I still think I
would prefer those over this plastic but
either way even if you don't get the
back color you like you don't need to
sell it or return it because the g4 is
part of an endangered species of
smartphones that still have a removable
back so you can remove the back and
replace it or use any of the other ones
you can switch between them
and underneath that removable back you
have access to a removable 3000 milliamp
hour battery and a micro SD card slot
for expandable storage so that will make
some people really happy
also LG kept all the buttons on the back
of the phone so there are no buttons on
either side it's nice and clean and you
have some slightly improved more tactile
buttons I think they're a little bit
more separated and the power volume up
and volume down really easy to press and
easy to get used to I actually found
myself reaching for back buttons on
other phones after using this one now
around the front of this phone is a 5.5
inch quad HD display again it's not an
OLED display like Samsung but it's what
LG calls a quantum IPS display not to be
confused with an actual quantum dot
display found in some new TVs but they
do promise it'll bring some deeper
contrast blacker blacks and better
overall color and yeah pretty much any
way you painted this display looks
awesome it gets very bright not quite as
bright as the galaxy s6 again outdoors
but it's close and of course it's super
sharp and very vibrant and colorful and
beautiful and curved and just enough to
make a difference when you're holding it
up to your face if you still make phone
calls so it might not be the dis best
display in any smartphone I'm still
gonna hand in that crown to the galaxy
s6 but the g4s panel provides a
fantastic media experience if only it
weren't paired with a bottom rear-facing
not that great easy to cover speaker
it's kind of loud but it really does the
display a disservice whether you're
watching your team dominate during the
regular season or watching them crumble
to an epic postseason collapse so when
it comes down to actually using this
phone we're rockin android 5.1 with LG's
UI on top the software experience is
sort of like a refined version of what
we had on the g3 it's a little bit
cleaned up a little bit smoother and it
adds a few pretty useful features
actually some of them notably copied
from rivals but hey at least they copied
the good stuff I personally still prefer
stock Android over this skinned version
but that's mostly for aesthetics and for
a lot of people that matters less and
there are a bunch of neat features in
here to make the g4 worth more so for
example besides the few pre-installed
apps and widgets you get that resizable
LG keyboard which i think was pretty
underrated with the g3 last year so if
you have smaller hands you can shrink
the keyboard down to match or bigger
hands you can make the keyboard bigger
if also brought in Samsung's dual window
you can take advantage of that whole
five and a half inch display by
multitasking with apps that support this
again it's not something I use very
often but it's still neat to see even if
we've seen it before it works pretty
well they also have these new smart
features which use context like location
and connectivity status to basically
automate stuff so I have mine set up for
example to open Spotify every time I
plug my headphones in which is pretty
convenient and you can have a change and
open things like when it connects to
your home Wi-Fi or when you turn
bluetooth on etc and then everything
else in LG's launcher is pretty smooth
and clean I mean again it's not as clean
as stock Android but it's a definite
improvement and I noticed things like
you know the super wordy version of the
weather in the stock weather widget
again like instead of the temperature I
get a paragraph or the settings I still
think are downright ugly they've
organized it really well and it's
helpful but any menu that needs the
scrolling text was probably not planned
very well but honestly that's just
nitpicking and performance throughout
this version of Android on the g4 has
been extremely solid gaming great web
browsing has been very smooth on Chrome
multitasking with a bunch of apps open
the g4 handled pretty much everything as
it should with three gigabytes of RAM
now on to the battery life of the LG g4
like I mentioned earlier it has a
removable back so the easiest quickest
way to replace her charge is to just
crack it open take the battery out and
replace it with a fresh one that you've
charged somewhere else that's the
easiest way to get your charge back and
that's only possible because it's a
removable backed phone now when we first
got the announcement we also heard that
it did not support Qualcomm quick
charging and did not support wireless
charging since that video one of those
things has changed it's gotten an update
now where it does support Qualcomm's
quick charging so that's pretty nice so
you have battery swap available you have
quick charging available still no
wireless charging but the battery life
of the phone itself with this 3000
milliamp hour battery is great I've been
getting great standby time and great on
screen time so I typically average
around 4 hours of screen on time with
the quad HD display and all of its great
performance and also standby time was
really good so I would go to sleep
unplugged at 100% and I would wake up
with 98 percent battery left which is
great you don't see that from every
phone so I'm happy to say that the g4
has been great in any aspect of battery
life even though it does get a little
bit warm
sometimes even though it does have a
really high-resolution really big
display there have been no problems and
it lasted me all day every day now on to
the camera on the back of the g4 since
this thing has launched this camera has
been one of the most talked about one of
the most impressive features to a lot of
people this has been the thing that's
blowing more people away than anything
else and rightfully so on paper we're
looking at a 16 megapixel one over two
point six inch sensor with a wide open F
1.8 aperture which is the widest on any
smartphone so far and an LED flash that
you'll hopefully never have to use also
to the left of the sensor is your laser
autofocus for fast and accurate focusing
and to the right under the flash is a
new color spectrum sensor for fast and
accurate white balance the camera
software itself is pretty clean so you
can double tap the volume down button on
the back of the phone when it's off to
open the camera but I wish it didn't
take a photo every time I did that but
when you open it you can see the auto
mode looks like any other smartphone
camera a separate button for photos or
4k video quick focus thanks to the laser
autofocus and tap to focus and meteor
work pretty well overall it's pretty
easy to use for anyone who's trying to
set it up but then the g4 has a few
tricks up its sleeve first is the new
manual mode similar to the galaxy s6 and
it's pro mode here you can choose
everything just like a DSLR from ISO to
white balance to shutter speed to the
manual focus distance and dial in that
perfect shot and then there's even a
toggle to switch to shooting RAW images
which you can actually take into
Lightroom or Photoshop and tweak the
data yourself just like with a DSLR shot
so that's really impressive so on to the
actual images on a beautiful quad HD
viewfinder it's easy to be very
impressed by the crispy photos the g4
takes there's tons of detail great
colors even pretty decent dynamic range
which is impressive for a smartphone
camera but yeah bringing them into a
computer and inspecting them actually
that left me more impressed pretty much
every photo I took was clean and intact
sharp focus and it very quickly became
one of those cameras that made me want
to just go out and take more photos of
things just encouraged me to point and
shoot in auto mode and it did a killer
job also the optical image stabilization
had me taking way more low-light shots
and a did great job with those two
dynamic range was wide enough to keep
those photos looking pretty balanced
even in more extreme situations
and the O is kept shots crispy no matter
what the conditions basically what I'm
saying is it's very hard to complain
about anything about the G for camera
but I do have something just one little
nitpick as much as we love crispy shots
the g4 does actually over sharpen a
little bit the same way Samsung phones
did one or two years ago take this shot
for example I took the same photo on
both the Galaxy s6 camera which you I've
talked about that phone a lot in this
video and the LG g4 camera both shots
looked fantastic on the phone's display
but inspecting them both on the computer
and zooming in the g4 photo was so much
sharper than the galaxy s6 is to the
point where I thought I actually missed
focus with the s6 camera but I didn't
the g4 just sharpens the image a lot
more on post-processing so you can see
it's crispier but it's not actually
showing any more detail the issue is a
little easier to see here in this photo
so the gnome is in focus but some of the
flowers aren't supposed to be but if you
zoom in and look at those flowers you
can see they're still processed in a way
that kind of tries to find detail and
crunch into focus things that aren't not
a huge deal especially when most people
never zoom in on their smartphone photos
anyway but this is something that can be
adjusted in a software update and I
think that's what we'll see otherwise
though don't let me ending on that note
give you a bad taste this is easily one
of the best cameras in any smartphone on
the g4 and I might not be able to
replace your DSLR like LG might want you
to think it does but damn we might need
to have another top smartphone cameras
comparison pretty soon oh and if you're
wondering it also has a front-facing 8
megapixel selfie camera in case you're
into that so overall at the end of the
day the g4 is an awesome phone in a lot
of ways I think my biggest problem with
it was just aesthetics like I didn't
think it was a prettiest phone I really
like the way the g3 looked with the
super thin bezels on the sides and the
top the g4 I think is a little more
boring in my opinion maybe if I had the
leather version I'd be a little bit
happier about the way it looked but not
a huge fan of the plastic not huge fan
of the sides that are kind of metallic
but still kind of slippery but otherwise
it's an awesome phone like the camera
the performance the battery life the
specs just the hardware in general it's
an awesome phone in pretty much every
other way to use and I think you'll be
happy with it it's especially if you
like the g3
this is gonna be an awesome phone to
pick up so yeah that's
hope you enjoyed this video review of
the LG g4 thank you for watching and if
you enjoyed it feel free to give it a
thumbs up below and hit that subscribe
button if you haven't already to see
more videos like this again thanks for
watching and talk to you guys the next
one bass